-Welcome back!
We're here with Jeff Goldblum.
Um, we're getting to some music.
You're musical.
-Okay.
-We have boys
about the same age.
-Yeah.
-And yours are still
doing piano.
I'm so impressed.
-Why? Yours were and stopped?
-Mine -- No, they're not doing
anything.
I mean...
[ Laughter ]
But do they --
Here's my question.
We've gotten them things
like guitars and drum sets,
and they like messing around
a little bit, but they don't --
There's no magnetism towards it.
Did your kids have it, like,
when they first started playing?
-I don't know that they had
a magnetism toward it,
but we exposed them to it,
offered them lessons.
The one went to Suzuki --
a Suzuki school.
He did okay with that.
And they have a good teacher --
Pippa.
Excuse me, I'm a little gassy.
[ Laughter ]
But --
-Just keep us updated.
-Yeah.
-You know.
-I will. I will.
But Pippa is very good,
and they're playing pretty well.
-Yeah.
-Yes, Charlie, the one that's 7,
is doing very well.
She's very thrilled with him.
He kind of plays by himself now.
He's off and running.
He likes it.
I think he considers himself
as kind of a pianist.
-And do you like hearing it?
Does it make you happy?
-Yes, it does.
And I kind of facilitate,
and so does Emilie.
He's practicing every day.
He practices every day.
That's what I missed out on
when I was a kid.
My mom didn't really
make me practice.
Maybe she -- That's okay, but I
finally kind of got into it.
Anyway, they're doing well.
I play a duet with Charlie.
We do "The Band Played On."
♪ Da-da-da-da, da-da-da,
da-da-da ♪
It's cute, and we do it for
other people.
We like to perform a little bit.
River also plays very well.
So they're doing okay.
-That's wonderful. I'm happy.
-Yeah.
Yours must be doing many things.
-They're doing many things,
but...
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Nothing where, like,
when you have friends over,
you're like,
"Wait till you get
a look at this," yeah.
-Well, it doesn't have to be.
It doesn't have to be.
River actually has so much
confidence. I don't know why.
He went -- He played piano,
but then he went, "Okay."
I said, "Hey, are you gonna tell
that joke?"
Because I'd told him a joke,
and then he kept repeating.
And I said, "You want to tell
everybody?"
And he was like, "Okay. Okay."
And then he told a joke,
and then he said,
"Okay, wait, wait,"
and he started to go into
a snap routine
'cause he'd just learned
to snap his fingers,
which is a big
kind of rite of passage.
And, anyway, he --
And then I joined in.
We did a little of that.
So...yours can do anything.
It's not the -- It's not --
-Yeah.
-It's they're qualified
if they just do it.
-There you go.
I wonder where he gets
his confidence, your son.
[ Laughter ]
-I seem to have confidence?
-You? I love -- Your energy is
one of my favorite energies
to be around --
everything about it.
You're so comfortable
being Jeff Goldblum.
It's my favorite thing.
[ Laughter ]
Now, Mildred Snitzer --
The Mildred Snitzer Orchestra...
-Yes, sir.
-...we've talked about the name
before,
because you've obviously
been on the show.
Mildred Snitzer was
an actual person,
a friend of your mother's?
-In Pittsburgh,
where my dad is from.
-Yeah, in The Burgh.
There you go.
-We love The Burgh.
-We love The Burgh here.
We love The Burgh.
-Love The Burgh.
The Steelers. Go Steelers.
-Yep.
-Yeah, Mildred Snitzer
was a lovely woman
who used to visit my mom,
and, you know.
-Was she -- Did she ever live to
know that her name was --
-You know, funny you should ask.
I don't think
I told anybody this,
but she lived, first of all,
to be about 102 or 104.
-Good for her.
-First of all.
And, in her 80s, 90s --
We've been playing out and about
for the last 30 years.
We had a weekly gig someplace
in California at the time.
We've moved around.
She was -- had moved
from Pittsburgh
to Northern California,
and one night --
I'll be darned -- John Mastro,
who was backstage, our manager,
said, "Guess who's here?
Mildred Snitzer."
-[ Laughs ]
-And she -- she -- she waltzed
in with some kind of sequined --
She'd dressed up
for the occasion.
She was dancing around.
She was 80 or 90.
Yeah. So she saw us.
How about that?
-Well, there you go.
And what song are you gonna
do first tonight?
-Ooh, we're going to do
a song...
[ Laughter ]
...that you know all too well.
Mattiel Brown --
the great Mattiel Brown --
is gonna sing it.
It's been arranged by Joe Bagg,
our virtuoso organ player.
And the name of the song is,
well, I'll give you a hint.
I'll bet you'll know it.
It's from -- It was sung
by Audrey Hepburn in a movie
called "Breakfast at Tiffany's."
[ Audience "Ooh"s ]
Of course, it's...
-"Moon River."
-"Moon River." There we go.
We got one. I knew it, so that's
the only reason I didn't say it.
[ Laughter ]
-And the first --
And the first two bars
go like this.
Listen to this.
♪ Moon ♪
You're gonna sing with me.
-Okay.
-♪ Moon...river ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Wider...than...a...♪
[ Both laugh ]
-Very good.
Hey, we're like Sandler & Young.
-We are like Sandler & Young.
-You don't know Sandler & Young.
-Adam Sandler and Burt Young.
[ Both laugh ]
-That's so good.
No, Adam Sandler --
Sandler & Young were big
on "The Merv Griffin Show."
-[ Laughs ]
Alright, well,
you're sticking around.
I can't believe my luck tonight.
You guys, that's Jeff Goldblum.
We're gonna be right back
with a performance --
Jeff Goldblum and
The Mildred Snitzer Orchestra.